okay so the movement
is not new the movement is the inward
spiral
it's in every technique or it's in
vertices in every technique
so the last time we were doing
it and did the echo disarm
then we started making it where he he
stops the notch
okay now it's still embryonic
just working on the disarm
boom clear boom
so our footwork is now going to come in
so clear the line
kazushi i'm going to do
boom clear
but just work the basics wolves
once you get the basics you're adding
your other hand
[Music]
reducing
oh so as i say my kiddo strategy
of course you can cut there but you
don't really have this balance you're
not really clearing the line
so your disarm is much better if i clear
the line if i take his balance and then
do the disarm
[Music]
don't get stuck on the throne it's not
that i'm
i'm throwing him i'm cutting him but i
cut from where i
am into his center i don't want to
push at the sake of throwing him i have
a weapon use the weapon
a home pull i'm in his center when i cut
boom clear pop boom
[Music]
so
all right oh i am in this case
but then he becomes young
so i i just am constantly
reenacting the same principles
so if he comes at me i start to fight
rotating
i use the same kazushi pattern
the same inverse spiral i follow the
same
universal principles so the two objects
come together
and then two objects will go apart
so same thing i'm coming in i'm going to
start the fight
rotating to full
rotate the fight two objects come
together
two objects come apart
[Music]
so have your tummy work
with you so you should have your cover
hand and then your strike is coming in
when we were here we've had a little
hand here because it's just
embryonic embryonic
oh we're trying to get past embryonic
form
so in a time
basic concept if he's grabbing
he's not defending so fill the gap
so
then to help us
we're going to do it this way so
i'm going to strike he's going to power
it
oh i'm going to strike and drop in
he's going to grab let's get out of this
aikido one hand fighting
we have to chew them and walk so
i'm in boom i drop boom he grabs
i do the technique
strike draw technique
hide your draw in the stride oh
oh if he doesn't grab it don't
fret just use your ik adhesion because
you'll block it
boom like you were just use your ikea
adhesion to take
balance then you're just attacking the
arm versus the disarm
boom there he got a grip and i'll cut
the grip
do one where you just catch it on the
inside there you go
just do the same adhesion
attack the arm
boom you're back where we started with
the disarm
adhesion
[Music]
grabs
his uh cover bomb this one okay
so i'm going to save the skies roll
hop and it's here like this so here i do
the same
kazushi
so again the sky is home into the same
position
pull back turn it
here
but now he's not driving you saw how
difficult it is
and then don't ask so much of your
kazushi
so oh that's it then you can use your
strips
so we went over the strip
generate that angle cancellation from
here
get the homologous shoulder
in the way of the cross lateral
shoulders
this is different this is me just
stripping without his balance
attack is balanced boom balance send the
string
okay so uh as i'm moving more from a
control idealized micro drill
you don't want to you don't want to
imagine that the
application looks exactly like that
i imagine it could because it's
mathematically
mathematically possible due to the
infinite nature
of what can happen but
there's a downside to it because the
more i move him
that's going to require more work for me
that's going to require more work
capacity
you don't really look for those things
in applications
so the kazushi in terms of an
application
is really about tilting his spine
and moving it into that spiral
it's not really about this whole thing
like this
that's more my study guide
so as i as i come in and i go
here you can see he's he's hitting he's
hitting so
he has a yog and i use the yawn to an
accident
adhesion to start that motion i i'm not
going to go
here and pull in my clasp with him and
the second i hit
he touches me i'm going into that
and then i'm only looking for the tilt
of that spine i'm only looking for the
energy to go into the kazushi pattern
so boom boom that's it
so let's take the 9000 sometimes it
jacks you up
so boom boom here clear
and what you're looking for is not to do
this
you don't have this balance
so boom
[Music]
so he's doing the maneuver
boom up he if he doesn't take me off
balance i can
i can do the same thing to him do it
like
he's got to get me at that mechanical
disadvantage
it looks like he can just swipe it right
but we're just right back where we
started
he has to get my balance boom and then
clear his weapon pop
that's it
good
good that's it okay
so i'm just gonna drill the fluidity
of it
[Music]
so
trying to start uh
expecting less i don't want the big
movement
i don't want to dig from here and i also
want to get rid of the positive
it's very fluid
[Music]
and then the tension goes out too when
i'm micro drilling the tension goes out
[Music]
you